i think teachers are heroes absolutely
yeah
teachers should should be celebrated way
more than entertainers let's be honest
they brought up oh my her mom is a
teacher too and you were like i love
talking about my mom yeah she's been a
bronx school teacher for 50 years
i had the most amazing dosage of musical
theater at a young age because i had an
amazing elementary school music teacher
barbara ames um shout out to barbara
ames
[Applause]
my whole thing is to find any way i can
to teach the whole child so i'm focusing
on not just their education but social
and emotional and so i use music in my
classroom so in my classroom i'm always
saying find your learning group and so
your learning group is however you move
wherever the music takes you as long as
you're focused on the education at hand
i didn't know anything about mariachi
back then i'm from puerto rico and we
played saw somebody
so i started studying i'm sorry you
started you learned an entire
genre of music
that's an amazing teacher
that's a lot of work
west virginia is
45th
state ranked academically that's pretty
sad when it was my 30th anniversary at
school
if we could just do something for read
aloud if we could um collect books
collect money whatever we got so many
books that my husband and i had to rent
a van so put them in bags put them in
the back drove out to west virginia it
was
wonderful i look at their challenges as
an opportunity to work with them and
empower their family
and really you know be that
that person that you know you can be
somebody and you're setting that great
example for your children by going out
there to provide you know the basic need
the essential needs so they can be
successful i'm so happy being in my
classroom i'm here but i miss them so ty
you have something that you want to tell
your mama right you really are my hero i
wouldn't be a teacher if it weren't for
you and i see the way that your students
look up to you
there's something you don't know
sometimes i stand outside your bedroom
door
and i listen to you teach every day you
bring joy and enthusiasm and such love
to your children you're this shining
light in this really really dark time
and i couldn't be prouder we got to help
heal these kids because we have to look
at this pandemic like an opportunity to
change the things that didn't work right
and we shouldn't forget this moment
we shouldn't forget it we should
remember you know what we learned about
ourselves and and use this to reflect on
how we can make things better i reached
out to amir on social media and i sent
him a message i mean what can someone
some english teacher halfway across the
world actually do it and a friend that i
grew up with in philadelphia reached out
to me and said i can get him out amir
shows up at my house and we're posting
pictures you know there's the tears
there's the all that stuff you know so i
get a message after i post a picture
from another strathaven student who
graduated in 2014. prepare yourself
he's an air force pilot he said mr haney
won't believe this he said i flew him
out he his wife and his kid i flew them
out um kevin and emir don't know this
but he's here today y'all no
you do so much for your students and you
shouldn't have to choose between a new
car and helping your kids so we wanted
to help so captain this is 5 000 worth
of school supplies
and jenny
they want to help read aloud west
virginia as well so dollar general is
giving them ready for this
fifty thousand dollars
[Applause]
it's not about surprise i do it here i
love what i do
what you don't know
is that
48 hours ago my team and i completely
flipped your classroom without you
knowing
here it is
[Applause]
all the lies that are changed here this
quote on the wall it always seems
impossible until it's done by nelson
mandela the lies that are going to be
changing this room
wow
[Music]
you